[Musica]
Io sono un climatologo mi occupo di
cambiamenti climatici da tantissimi anni
oggi volevo darvi una prospettiva un po'
diversa da quello che faccio in genere
nelle mie
presentazioni oggi vorrei che voi
pensaste a il clima come a una specie di
filo che ci connette con il futuro e con
il passato con le generazioni del futuro
e con le generazioni del passato questo
perché il sistema climatico ha in sé
delle componenti di memoria molto lunga
per esempio gli oceani che hanno una
grande inerzia le foreste i ghiacciai
che sono gli archivi del clima della
storia del clima e che purtroppo stanno
scomparendo e anche l'atmosfera
l'atmosfera si evolve velocemente però
in sé alcuni gas climalteranti i
cosiddetti gas serra conine carboniche e
metano che sono dei gas che hanno tempi
di permanenza in atmosfera molto lunghi
decine se non centinaia di anni Questo
significa che se noi pertur biamo il
clima oggi queste perturbazioni si
trasmetteranno per molte decadi nel
futuro e che il clima di oggi dipende da
quello che è successo nelle nelle decadi
e n centinaia di anni del passato quindi
In altre parole il sistema climatico ci
fa come dire comunicare connettere con
generazioni che non sono ancora lì sulle
nostre scelte di
sviluppo dico scelte perché ci sono
diversi futuri a seconda di quello che
decideremo di fare nei prossimi anni da
quando è iniziata l'era cosiddetta era
del petrolio No una una società basata
sull'uso dei combustibili fossili a
Carbone petrolio gas naturale
sicuramente abbiamo innalzato il nostro
livello di vita però abbiamo anche
cominciato a modificare il clima globale
Io vorrei che questo sia chiaro a tutti
non so se ci siano degli scettici in
aula ma oggi la comunità scientifica usa
la parola
inequivocabile quando parla per esempio
delle quantità di gasera in atmosfera
che oggi sono le più
alte almeno negli ultimi 125.000 anni a
causa delle attività umane soprattutto
l'uso di combustibili fossili e alcune
pratiche agricole e la comunità
scientifica usa la parola inequivocabile
Anche quando dice che questo aumento di
gas serra sta producendo un
riscaldamento globale
che anch'esso è senza precedenti per la
sua velocità almeno negli ultimi 11.000
anni vorrei che questo fosse chiaro
fosse chiaro a tutti e se le emissioni
di gassera continueranno ad aumentare al
ritmo attuale potremmo arrivare a
qualcosa come almeno questo è quello che
ci dicono i nostri modelli 4-5 gr di
riscaldamento globale entro la fine del
secolo e questo il nostro pianeta non lo
ha visto direi meno per gli ultimi due
se non 3 milioni di anni quindi il
pianeta sta vivendo veramente un periodo
storico del tutto senza
precedenti le conseguenze se si
arrivasse veramente a 45° di
riscaldamento globale sarebbero Io direi
addirittura
difficili non solo da predire Ma anche
in un certo senso da immaginare però
purtroppo queste conseguenze già sono
qui fra di noi già le vediamo oggi
e storia addirittura di questi
giorni l'aumento di cosiddetti fenomeni
meteorologici estremi dovuto
all'intensificazione del ciclo
idrologico legata al riscaldamento
globale quindi aumento di intensità e
frequenza di alluvioni siccità ondate di
calore ormai Questi li vediamo
praticamente tutti gli anni la fusione
dei ghiacciai la fusione ghiacciai è
importantissima perché i ghiacciai sono
i nostri maggiori serbatoi di acqua
acqua potabile e quindi perdere
ghiacciai significa Perdere acqua e già
oggi di acqua non ce n ha sufficienza
l'innalzamento del livello del mare Ecco
magari per Pavia Questo non è un grande
problema ma per una città come Trieste
come Venezia tutte le coste del mondo
dove vino miliardi di persone questo è
un problema gravissimo importantissimo
la perdita di abitabilità di alcune zone
tropicali per l'eccessivo stress termico
soprattutto nelle città in queste grandi
megalopoli urbane e
tropicali e poi stiamo facendo adesso
difficile addirittura spiegare quello
che stiamo facendo al Pianeta lo stiamo
ricoprendo di
rifiuti inquinamento di area e acqua
dissesto
idrogeologico deforestazione insomma
questo pianeta è veramente in questo
momento sotto assedio Sotto assedio da
noi
purtroppo ed è uned
che peggiorerà sempre se non cerchiamo
veramente di fare qualcosa per per
cambiare cambiare le cose Volevo farvi
un altro esempio che ancora guarda al
futuro Quanti di voi hanno sentito
parlare del Earth overshoot Day alzate
la mano Ah qualcuno c'è allora l'er Day
è quel giorno dell'anno in cui noi
abbiamo collettivamente
consumato tutte le biorisorse che il
pianeta produce in un anno va bene
allora l'anno scorso 2022 questo Earth
overs Day è stato il 28 luglio Questo
significa che dal 29 luglio al 31
dicembre abbiamo dovuto intaccare quelli
che sono i depositi di biorisorse per
esempio con la pesca eccessiva o con la
deforestazione delle grandi foreste
pluviali Questo significa che noi stiamo
lasciando in eredità al futuro un
pianeta più povero di quello che noi
abbiamo
ereditato dalle generazioni
precedenti e questo ovviamente una cosa
che dovrebbe farci riflettere molto sul
valore etico Delle nostre scelte per
fortuna allora finora AV fatto tutte
brutte notizie siete tutti depressi e
così via però diciamo la buona notizia
da qui comincia qualche buona notizia e
che la scienza oggi ci dice che possiamo
ancora scegliere non abbiamo ancora
raggiunto il cosiddetto punto di non
ritorno no Io ricevo questa domanda da
amici da conoscenti da
studenti molto spesso ma è troppo tardi
non possiamo fare più niente No non solo
non abbiamo raggiunto il punto di non
ritorno Ma non abbiamo raggiunto la
cosiddetta soglia di pericolo quella
soglia al di là della quale gli effetti
dei cambiamenti climatici possono
veramente mettere a repentaglio lo
sviluppo sostenibile della società
perlomeno della società come oggi la
conosciamo
questa soglia di pericolo è stata
identificata nell'accordo di Parigi del
2015 Vedete qui un'immagine su questo
accordo nei due gradi di riscaldamento
globale rispetto a Val valori
preindustriali Che significa un grado
più o meno rispetto ai valori
attuali un grado rispetto a valori
attuali significa che non siamo lontani
da questa da questa soglia però ci sono
tantissimi studi che ci dicono che è
possibile rimanere al di sotto se si
agisce in maniera veloce ed in maniera
efficace Che cosa vuol dire
sostanzialmente la transizione ecologica
quello che oggi viene chiamato
transizione ecologica
adesso la transizione ecologica non è
una bacchetta magica non c'è niente No
La gente pensa Sì si inventerà la
fusione nucleare o qualsiasi cosa che ci
salverà in realtà non è così la
transizione ecologica è un insieme di di
soluzioni di politiche che vanno in un
certo senso incastrate come i tasselli
di un
mosaico qui vedete alcuni esempi la
decarbonizzazione del sistema energetico
il passaggio ad energie rinnovabili
pulite la riforestazione la l'energia
circolare l'energia a Kilometro 0 ci
sono l'idrogeno verde ne avete sentito
parlare e
oggi questo mosaico di questa
transizione ecologica è diverso da
nazione a nazione Perché tutte le
nazioni hanno Esigenze diverse nei paesi
ricchi cosiddetti
ricchi o cosiddetti industrializzati di
questa transizione ecologica è già
iniziata Secondo me
inarrestabile nonostante qualche
tentativo diciamo così però è importante
che questo avvenga anche nei paesi
emergenti nei paesi cosiddetti in via di
sviluppo che hanno tutto il diritto a
svilupparsi ma è importante che questo
sviluppo avvenga in un ambito di
economia verde e i paesi ricchi devono
aiutare i Paesi
poveri a far sì che questo avvenga con
un trasferimento tecnologico a costi
contenuti altrimenti è sostanzialmente
inutile Però ci sono tanti studi che ci
dicono che questo è possibile questo è
l'anima di tutto il dibattito a livello
internazionale in questo comitato che ha
vinto appunto Il il il premio Nobel e la
transizione ecologica non dobbiamo
averne paura Io ogni tanto all TV sento
perché dobbiamo fare questo sacrificio
la transizione ecologica non è un
sacrificio
ma anzi dobbiamo vederla come una
opportunità di
sviluppo di innovazione perché alla fine
porterà ad un miglioramento della vita
di tutti
quanti ma la transizione ecologica
dipende da scelte va bene scelte che
sono scelte individuali e scelte
collettive sono scelte su politiche
energetiche su politiche tecnologiche
eh economiche ma soprattutto Secondo me
è una scelta culturale dobbiamo
veramente cambiare il paradigma
culturale oggi noi viviamo una in una
cultura sostanzialmente predatoria delle
risorse del pianeta va bene predatore
significa che prendiamo le risorse
senza considerare le conseguenze perché
le rit le riteniamo nostre dobbiamo
passare da questo paradigma ad un
paradigma in cui noi siamo parte stessa
del pianeta e quindi vogliamo
salvaguardarne la salute che significa
salvaguardare la nostra salute
e queste
scelte diciamo così individuali possono
sembrare non so come delle gocce
nell'oceano ognuno di voi si dirà sì ma
che cosa posso fare io per cambiare
questo pianeta così grande In realtà
dobbiamo renderci conto che tutte le
nostre azioni si dicevano volta ai tempi
in cui ero ragazzo avevo l'età di tanti
ragazzi qui ogni nostra azione è
un'azione politica oggi possiamo dire
ogni nostra azione è un'azione che
cambia il pianeta un pochino come una
goccia nell'oceano Ma se mettiamo
insieme 7 miliardi di persone possiamo
veramente
cambiare questo pianeta ed il futuro e
ogni azione cambia anche una cultura
quando iamo un albero quando
salvaguardiamo un bosco una specie in
estinzione quando usiamo energia dal
sole dall'acqua dal vento quando siamo
una comunità energetica qu sono tutte
azioni mille altre azioni che creano una
cultura che si trasmette nel tempo e
nello spazio a tutti gli altri e queste
sono azioni nella nostra vita quotidiana
poi queste azioni
devono trasmettersi in azioni collettive
rappresentate dai nostri governi
governi che purtroppo adesso sembrano
essere
veramente come dire
insensibili a quello che è il lamento
del pianeta chiamiamolo così a queste
grandi crisi le grandi crisi di questo
secolo saranno crisi
ambientali va bene eppure nessuno sembra
rendersene conto però siamo noi che
leggiamo i governi E siamo noi i
consumatori mi sembra che si parlerà di
consumo fra poco quindi noi possiamo
poss
indirizzare i mercati possiamo
indirizzare il futuro abbiamo una grande
forza se agiamo
collettivamente un'altra cosa importante
voi Noi siamo in un certo senso
fortunati perché stiamo vivendo un
periodo unico nella storia della
civilità umana Almeno io la penso così è
un periodo in cui siamo la prima
generazione o le prime generazioni che
sono
consapevoli di essere davanti ad un
bivio che è fondamentale per il futuro
della
civiltà lo vedete qui da un lato c'è una
strada che porta un
pianeta più povero più inquinato più
ostile alla razza
umana alla razza umana più ostile alla
civiltà
umana una civiltà da enormi differenze
socioeconomiche perché poi la riduzione
della povertà è un elemento fondamentale
per la
resilienza se avete visto il film Blade
Runner Ecco più o meno Questo è uno dei
futuri è una delle strade l'altra è un
pianeta più pulito più ricco che può
ancora nutrirci che può
ancora come dire più accogliente che può
fornire tutto quello che serve allo
sviluppo sostenibile della società come
oggi la conosciamo e ogni volta che c'è
un video ovviamente ci sono delle scelte
abbiamo visto Sono scelte difficili ma
sono scelte che vanno prese soprattutto
dai ragazzi sono contento di vedere così
tanti ragazzi oggi devo dire questo non
sempre succede quindi grazie viia
direi perché sono i ragazzi che devono
trovare queste vie come dire
innovative in economia in tecnologia E
in cultura anche a livello culturale che
possano indicare una una nuova una nuova
direzione la cosa importante è rendersi
conto che la scelta c'è Noi siamo Spesso
bombardati ormai da decenni dal
messaggio che non c'è alternativa a Come
va il mondo in realtà non è così ce lo
dice la scienza perché l'economia verde
è del tutto competitiva con l'economia
fossile quindi siamo davanti
essenzialmente a una questione di
scelta si parlava del futuro pensate
al alle scelte che faremo nei prossimi
anni come un messaggio una bottiglia che
viaggia nel tempo trasportato dal
clima un giorno i nostri figli e i figli
dei nostri figli vi siete molto giovani
ma Credetemi prima o poi avrete anche
voi dei figli
leggeranno Questo messaggio lo
leggeranno nell'aria che respireranno
nell'acqua che
verranno nella pioggia che nutrirà i
loro i loro raccolti nel mare e nelle
foreste che li nutrirà e se avremo preso
la strada
giusta allora loro sapranno questi
nostri figli che la nostra scelta è
stata di non
abbandonarli e io sono sicuro che tutti
i genitori in questo teatro e anche
tutti
i più giovani quando saranno genitori
converranno con me che questo è uno dei
doni più preziosi che la vita ci può
fare
[Applauso]
Grazie